[Music]
First of all,
I’m on the mound like Horizon
Even though we meet, I go in to be pulled in as if it were the first time I met
Chatting Dyne
n2 Chat Mining 7n Tell me about the baby chicken
I'm scattered and I don't think
I can wake up right away I just use my phone for a bit
and it's easy to get lost and it's big Everything And I always dream often, but
lead  I know this dream cutter from my family and friends today,
so it's not fun. In
fact, many people
remind me of Neverland 6. Neverland overflows with sensationalism 9 As
a singer brand that sang something of hope, you are
still singing those songs, Holland  It
may have changed a little bit, but the bass is still
talking about Kim Ha-ji and I'm leaving it as Holland, a story about love.
So, the song I want to recommend is 4 Neverland, and
after 19, isn't it a matter of taste?
Yes, probably when I was in middle school, k-pop idol SHINee sunbaenim paid a divorce at that time
. I just followed SHINee. There are some people who really know me, but after Music Bank
, I make it with Paul’s music, etc.
I feel like I was influenced by you a little bit more
now, it’s been consistently good for 4 days and my tastes don’t seem to change
And for example, about 3 people, even if we touch them on the 3rd, we have a
concert. The
first time, the first, the second
, the middle, and the third, the
last one. The second one is right.
I think it's not just standing
, I watched it from the back seat from a distance, but it was still pretty good.
Rising while watching Choi Hee sunbaenims As a keeper by the lake I
have a dream and do things that are good for me now Rick
I am a kor
d'or in my time We
are up to about 100 uh ncp Now we are still active and posting 5
So many people came and went, but SHINee has access to it  There
has never been a time when BIGBANG was really the best.
Whether it was G-Dragon 305 or Chinese seniors
, I've been dreaming of becoming a k-pop idol since I've been watching a lot now.
Right after I entered university
, I started to think again about what I really want to do. So
1 I work really hard, earn money, study, and do something. Studying the entertainment side
is not my major in university, but I secretly went in and listened to lectures.
There's a specific contrast, and if you go with a blend like this,
please tell me what will happen. See you
next time. No ooh
la loo